rise of the Tomb Raider unfolds in a
valley haunted by echoes of older times
and for Lara Croft a person intent on
escaping her past this is not a
comforting place the result is a balance
almost seamless experience that pulls us
through world will come to know on an
intimate level rise of the Tomb Raider
anchors Lara's story with its own
believable characters an emotional
weight but Crystal Dynamics doesn't use
any magic elements as a storytelling
crutch it injects the mystical in a way
that makes sense within the world they
occupy and as a third-person adventure
game rise of the Tomb Raider excels
rather than collide gameplay and story
share the same space supplementing each
other and emerging as a cohesive whole
right to the tomb raider is open but it
isn't exactly a sandbox new areas are
gated by ability unlocks there are also
more actual tombs this time around the
cutscenes here are succinct but not
without substance they get the story
across but they don't get in the way and
in combat rise of the Tomb Raider superb
the variety of options available in any
given firefight is staggering and make
each one feel like its own puzzle rise
of the tomb Raider's opening shots
promised a grand adventure waiting ahead
of us and at the end of the journey
after we've seen Laura through it's
clear that promise was kept we're close
to something Jonah I can feel it